well joining me now for more on this is
retired Air Vice Marshal Sean Bell hi
again Sean uh an extraordinary
acknowledgment there by the Russian
military and this the deadliest attack
uh for Russia since the start of this
war let's start with what you know about
what happened in the cafe yeah it's
always worth starting with um what we
know the ukrainians did a strike at
mcivka which is here it's only about 13
kilometers uh east of the front line and
some of the fierce is fighting in the
donbass region the Russians have set up
a temporary uh Barracks facility in a
school which we've got a picture of uh
here unfortunately in the school at the
basement of the school they're also
storing a lot of weapons and artillery
and it also appears they had lots of
storage of the artery shells around the
facility as well on New Year's Eve
shortly after midnight the ukrainians
use the high Mars rocket system the
American system Fara Salvo six Rockets
two of which the Russians claimed to
shut down but four made their way
through with devastating consequences
we've got some images of before and
after here which we can show they quite
grainy images but we how like this is
the school we've just been seeing this
white blob here and it's in the middle
of a town which is worth pointing out we
see the after images as well after the
strike which is just in the new year and
the facility has been completely
destroyed but what I draw your attention
to is that if you looked at any other
Villages and towns in the donbass that
the Russians have been fighting in the
whole area is devastated the advantage
of having Precision weapons is that that
Target's been destroyed but largely the
rest of the village in town has been
untouched and of course as we've seen
throughout this war there's a war of
words as well both sides reporting this
incident uh very differently and a big
discrepancy in terms of casualty numbers
yes we've always got to take a bit of a
pinch of salt because both sides both
the Russians and Ukrainian always come
out with slightly different numbers the
ukrainians said 400 Russians died and
300 injured the Russians actually
strangely very quickly counted and said
they'd lost 63 but that's been updated
to 89 subsequently independent experts
have said that there were over 600
military personnel here at the time
um and but when you look at the the
devastation of the building and the fact
almost certainly this was caused by
other ammunition that was stored in the
basement it's very difficult to see any
Russians would have got out of this
unscathed and whatever the actual
numbers are many of those who injured
would never return to the war again and
many are tragedy will probably die of
their injuries as you said it's the
deadliest strike since the start of the
war
and the Russian military have have also
said that these Russian soldiers were
targeted and identified in terms of
their location because of the use of
personal mobile phones is that is that
the case tell us more about that yeah
it's very simple to tell exactly what
the cause was but it's worth actually it
does illustrate that Russians are
fighting a sort of 20th century warfare
that's been their recent experience when
they fought in chechnya they've been
fighting low-tech enemies they fight a
war of attrition and even in Ukraine the
Russians have been firing twenty
thousand rounds of artillery every
single day unguided leveling the
battlefield Ukraine has been supported
by the West weapons like this high mass
system here trying to use far more
accuracy these can strike their weapon
their targets very accurately we need to
know where the target is and that needs
intelligence now intelligence can come
from all sorts of things from satellite
technology from drones but also return
to the theme of mobile phones it can
come from tracking Communications phones
can be triangulated for position and
also listening to now Russians do have
secure radios but because of the
corruption in the Russian military they
don't have enough now if not everybody
has a secure communication nobody can
have them and therefore the Russians
have become increasingly reliant on
mobile phones for communication New
Year's Eve everybody celebrates you can
imagine the conscripts calling their
family lots of the mobile phones light
up
identified as a Target and then with
tragic consequences and it's a really
Dreadful example of a Russian military
shortcomings which they really should be
learning better 10 months into the war
yeah and a very Stark example of their
operational security at Sean for now
thank you